shot one go holiday the rebound throws  it ahead the portis  quartus goes up knocked out of his hands  out of bounds  and it's still going to be milwaukee  ball portis trying to block chris paul  from  talking to scott foster that's a bizarre  sequence  you think you'd want to let him go maybe  hope should get mad and get a table  i'll tell you what this crowd loves  bobby porters and if you're a bucks fan  you have every right to if you like  competitors  you're going to like bobby portis  they've made t-shirts up in fact pat  conaton wore it the other day  for the media session t-shirts that say  bobby bobby bobby the chance he's been  hearing throughout these playoffs  so we'll take a timeout port is able to  smile here  for the most important game of his life  oh  oh